[Music]
this is my four-year-old son he's
basically van gogh
i got a piece for a rainbow mommy
his latest work might not look like much
but it's one of a kind at least
digitally it is since you know i
recently minted it as an nft on the
ethereum blockchain
as one does
oh and then i gave it to my mom in an
ethereum wallet
business
i expect you have no idea what any of
that meant
and i didn't either until i embarked on
this project now what the hell's an nft
for the nft nfts nfts yes nfts or
non-fungible tokens are the thing right
now you've got artists selling nfts of
their works some for millions of dollars
you've got musicians selling nft songs
and audio you've got brands like burger
king the nba and macy's making nfts
i could go on and on but underlying that
vast and wild assortment is the same
idea these are unique irreplaceable and
verifiable digital things
okay but why would you want one
authenticity yeah web 3 which is
after web 2 to impress
people it's a great though tough
question and we're going to get there
but first you need to understand what an
nft is and the best way to do that
make or buy one yourself
okay so this is my son's art or what he
calls
a masterpiece rainbow unicorn you want
to call her nft
no
no boring
he made it with physical stuff and then
i quickly turned it digital i scanned it
with my iphone and asked a colleague to
animate some of the parts i ended up
with this basic mp4 video file sure i
could just upload it to the web or some
social media platform but there nobody
knows that this is the real original
thing that it's not just some digital
copy
there's nothing no digital info that
says this is the masterpiece unicorn
rainbow nft made by my son that's what
minting it into an nft does
yep minting which is the first piece of
jargon you need to understand not these
mints minting in nft is the process of
taking a piece of content a jpeg an mp4
an mp3 some other file and putting it on
a digital registry
in this process you're recording the
stamp of ownership on a blockchain
jargon term number two blockchain
now this could be its own video but
here's the simple explanation the
blockchain is a software network where
computers run separate copies of the
same program
the computers are linked but no one
controls the network it's called a
decentralized network and it processes
transactions it also keeps a ledger or
database with records of every single
transaction that happens
every transfer every purchase etc there
are many blockchains including the one
for bitcoin the crypto you've probably
heard all about
got all that
alright back to nft making i decided to
mint the great rainbow unicorn using a
service called chip but to get started
on chip i needed to make a crypto wallet
think of it like a real wallet but only
for the cryptocurrencies and nfts that
you own for a specific blockchain
for this project i went with the gold
standard for nfts eth it's the
cryptocurrency associated with the
ethereum blockchain
metamask is one of the most popular eth
wallets even though i was making an nft
i needed ethereum for various associated
fees which i'll get to
so i bought some on coinbase a crypto
exchange where you can buy and sell lots
of different currencies and then
transferred that to my metamask ethereum
wallet
finally i was ready i gave the nft a
title and description and then uploaded
it to mint but before it was official i
had to pay what's called a gas fee for
this one i went straight to jeff gluck
the co-founder and ceo of chip
on the ethereum blockchain
gas refers to the cost necessary to
conduct a transaction on the ethereum
network it's a cost associated with
powering the network there are fees
associated with other blockchain
networks but typically ethereum is known
to have some of the highest gas fees
so i paid the gas fee point zero three
three three three eth or 145 dollars and
18 cents and boom
[Music]
it's on the blockchain
i could even confirm it by going to
etherscan.io
which has a record of every transaction
on the blockchain okay so now i could do
a few things with this nft masterpiece
including sell it
and oh boy are there a lot of digital
art nfts for sale out there
openc the biggest nft marketplace has
millions of pieces
and some of them have crazy high
valuations
look at this cool cat 6133
the highest offer was 26 000 as of
making this video why so much
some of these new nft projects such as
the cool cats these are some of the most
uh in-demand most exciting nft projects
that are that are out there right now
because of the way that they engage a
community around their project they have
in real life meetups events people
connect i didn't sell or list the
masterpiece unicorn rainbow because i'm
not in the art business but selling is
pretty easy once you get to this point
you go to open c set a minimum price and
see what happens
just like ebay buying an nft doesn't
take as many steps as making or selling
one but most sites like openc require
you have a crypto wallet but remember
you're gonna pay a gas fee on top of the
price of the art which makes this all
very expensive instead of selling i
decided to gift my nft to my mom
daughter of the year right here
her very own metamask ethereum wallet
yep in that envelope i put her new
metamask wallet information which
contains her new nft what in the world
this is your crypto wallet which inside
it has an nft made by your grandson why
would i want this
and that's really the question of the
year
why would you want an nft
after speaking with lots of people for
this story
i came up with a few reasons
one this is an elaborate high-tech
energy-sapping way to make money because
well people and companies like money
then there's the idea of owning digital
assets in the metaverse that is the
coming virtual world where we work and
shop and hang out then there's that cool
cat's idea you buy an nft to gain access
to a community another popular one is
called the board apes yacht club with
members like steph curry and jimmy
fallon
and then finally you love an artist or
brand and you want to own something
unique from them
which i can confidently say is exactly
how i feel about my favorite nft artist
nft
n f
what does it mean
poop